okay this is not the most important
story of the day but it is one of those
if they're lying about this what else
are they lying about types of stories
not this past Friday but the one before
it was reported that Donald Trump was
brought down to the bunker below the
White House for his safety and this is
it's not actually something to laugh at
these are decisions
Secret Service makes about the safety of
the president but Donald Trump kept
tweeting and acting like a big man and
some started pointing out you know big
tough Trump won't go near the protesters
and instead tweets from the safety of
his basement bunker so Trump was
triggered by this he came out and he
denied that he went to the bunker for
safety reasons he said oh I did I
decided I wanted to go down and inspect
the bunker on that particular day this
was what he told Fox & Friends a few
days after the incident they don't
Leland Verret Vitter reporting no
problem we've got dark a huge problem he
was attacked and then the reports were
there was so we read they brought you
downstairs and the White House to a
bunker what could you tell me something
like Sunday night was like for you and
your family well it was a false report I
was at then I went down during the day
and I was there for a tiny little short
period of time it was much more for an
inspection there was no problem during
the day the problem I saw Leland got
whacked pretty good but that was during
the night and this problem these
problems are during the night that
during the day and I go down I've gone
down two or three times all for
inspection and you go there someday you
may need it but you go there and I went
down I looked at it it was during the
day it was not a problem and I read
about it like a big thing there was
never a problem we never had a problem
nobody ever came close to giving us a
problem the Secret Service it does an
unbelievable job of maintaining control
of the White House right Trump claiming
that he regularly inspects the bunker
for no other reasons then I guess to
make sure that it's up to his
construction standards so this was
obviously not true when he said it but
now hilariously Donald Trump's own
attorney General William bar said no
Secret Service recommended
go down to the bunker this is from
yesterday it was a Fox News interview
with Bret bear and bar doesn't even
pretend he just admits to the entire
thing and the context was bar defending
just how dangerous it was last Monday
when protesters had to be cleared with
gas and and horses and bar saying you
know it was so crazy that we had to have
that the Secret Service recommend that
Trump go down to the bunker a lot of
talk about Monday kind of reliving the
moment there in Lafayette Park if you
had to do Monday over again would you do
something different based on what I know
now you know on Monday we were reacting
to three days of extremely violent
demonstrations right across from the
White House a lot of injuries to police
officers arson the things were so bad
that the Secret Service recommended the
president go down to the bunker we can't
have that in our country oh okay so
Secret Service did recommend Trump go to
the bunker because Trump said he was
inspecting it on what just happens to be
the same day that Secret Service
recommended that he go down there so I
don't want to beat a dead horse
we all knew Trump was obviously lying
when he said he was inspecting the
bunker but the reminder is if he lied
about this what else is he willing to
lie about and the answer is everything
he's willing to lie about everything now
just to warn you at some point the
defense is going to come out and they
are going to say bar never said Trump
went to the bunker because of the secret
service bar said the Secret Service
recommended from go to the bunker and
Trump didn't except to inspect the
bunker on the same day not because
Secret Service recommended it it's nuts
and it's just you know it's one little
example of this by the way I didn't get
to this but speaking of lying ten days
ago Trump mentioned that he spoke to the
Indian Prime Minister and the Indian
prime minister said that he was not in a
good mood about what was going on with
China
that conversation never happened so just
again the constant lies Indian Prime
Minister Narendra Modi has not spoken
with Donald Trump about the South Asian
nations military standoff with China but
Donald Trump claimed that a conversation
took place about that and Modi was in a
really bad mood like it just didn't
happen that conversation didn't happen
so he's lying about the bunker he's
lying about conversations he's lying
about everything that's the real
takeaway don't forget it
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time check out one of my
all-time favorite apps called blink it's
blink Isleta consume an entire book on
your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blink Asst blink east
has books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about 8 bucks a month and you get the
entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video